miren primer lugar a mal osman zonco Es
un personaje político que es muy poco
conocido en esta región del mundo por
favor Comencemos con quién es este
hombre Y por qué causó tanto revuelo su
caso en senegal absolutamente Ángela
Entonces usmann sunco es el adversario
político más conocido del presidente
maquisal es el líder de un partido
político que se llama Patriot África
giuse y también es candidato declarado a
las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo año 2024 es importante señalar
que es sin duda el oponente más serio
del presidente porque es muy popular
entre los jóvenes especialmente entre
aquellos que rechazan firmemente otro
mandato de maquisal que está en el poder
desde el 2012 un tercer mandato que
según la Constitución Además no está
permitido otra cosa que le ha hecho
popular entre los jóvenes son sus
opiniones muy patrióticas y muy
antioccidentales
en particular anti Francia por eso desde
la apertura de los casos judiciales en
su contra enfrentamientos entre la
policía y sus partidarios han estallado
regularmente en este país país senegal
conocido por ser relativamente estable y
no a la región como como el que es muy
turbulenta bueno son ha defendido que
este juicio en su contra por violación
es un juicio político más que nada y con
otros intereses usted puede explicarnos
En qué consistió este proceso y en qué
consiste la sentencia absolutamente
Entonces osmanzucon se enfrentó a dos
casos judiciales que tuvieron una gran
repercusión mediática el primero fue una
acusación presentada contra él por un
ministro del gobierno de maquisal que
señaló a sunco de difamación son perdió
este caso y fue condenado en mayo a seis
meses de prisión pero el caso que más
tensión causó en la opinión pública fue
el de las acusaciones de presunta vio
presentadas por una antigua empleada de
un salón de masajes la fiscalía había
pedido contra sunco diez años por
violación y cinco años por corrupción de
menores el caso causó mucha división en
senegal y por fin después de mucha
expectativa El veredicto se conoció este
jueves usmansonco fue condenado a dos
años de cárcel por corrupción de jóvenes
Qué significa esto en la legislación
senegaleza se trata de una disposición
que condena cualquier acto considerado
inapropiado hacía un joven menor de 21
años la ex masajista que acusó a sonko
era menor de 21 años en el momento de
los supuestos hechos Así que en resumen
fue absuelto de violación pero condenado
por corrupción de menores ahora él y sus
partidarios denuncian un complot
denuncias denuncian estos juicios como
unos complots para condenarle con el fin
de apartarle de la política lo cual no
sería demasiado extraño si uno tiene que
ambos crímenes estarían relacionados
finalmente qué es lo que ocurre ahora en
cuanto a su elegibilidad política que es
lo que está en juego en las calles es lo
que está en juego efectivamente Y cómo
ha sido condenado a una pena de prisión
a priori no es elegible pero tampoco es
una cuestión tan sencilla sin duda habrá
recursos sus abogados si ya han
anunciado que utilizarán todos los
medios legales a su alcance para que
pueda presentarse a las elecciones del
año que viene como No asistió a su
juicio Ángela que boicoteo no tiene
derecho a apelar no tiene derecho a
viral pero ahora queda por ver lo que va
a ocurrir y sobre todo como va a
reaccionar la calle senegaleza ante este
veredicto recordamos que en 2021 hubo
disturbios tras su detención en relación
con este mismo caso disturbios que se
salvaron con 14 muertos el riesgo ahora
es que la violencia se intensifique es
lo que hay que decir por el momento
Angela sobre el caso de